THE OTHER.
>> Bret: WE'VE GOT BREAKING
STORIES NOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE
DECISIONS ABOUT CLEMENCY FOR
THREE U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS.
THEY ARE AN EXECUTIVE GRANT OF
CLEMENCY, AND A PARDON FOR CLINT
LORENZ WHO WAS CONVICTED OF
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER FOR
ORDERING HIS SOLDIERS OPENING
FIRING AND KILLING THREE MEN IN
AFGHANISTAN.
FOR MERE
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDT
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDI
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDN
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDA
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDC
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDS
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDD
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDI
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDL
, FORMER ARMY MAJOR MATTHEWGOLDA
PATELLA BIDEN THON MAKER.
AND EDDIE GALLAGHER REINSTATED
BEFORE HIS TRIAL WHEN HE WAS
ACQUITTED OF WOUNDING AND ICE IS
A TEENY BUT FOUND GUILTY OF A
LESSER CHARGE, TAKING A
PHOTOGRAPH OF A SEPARATE DEAD
ISIS FIGHTER, GRANTED FULL
CLEMENCY BUT HOW ABOUT THIS?
>> I DON'T OF THE DETAILS OF THE
STORY SO I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO
WEIGH IN ON THE DETAILS.